when I'm not doing the voice this
particular time around I'm working on
multiple albums one being a follow-up to
my debut Spanish album a few solo
projects with some incredible producers
from I'm reuniting with to make classic
magic with I'm super super excited I'm
more inspired than I've been in a really
long time and it's a really really
exciting time for me I took a trip to
Ecuador which I'm half-irish from my
mom's side and half Latin half
Ecuadorian and I've never been to where
my father was born I go to see the
hungry as a UN ambassador for world
hunger with the World Food Program and
we go into the fields where Aid is
really needed it's the most amazing
humbling awesome experience giving back
a little
no one said my name not one person Luxio
then my beautiful backyard where it's
suppose n and tranquil and peaceful when
I get to sort of reflect I think we all
could use that in our day-to-day lives
in every every sense no matter what you
do no matter who you are when you want
something so bad like things sometimes
do get in their way and it's like nobody
works harder than a mom having been
pregnant my daughter is now 14 months
walking and talking mama needs to get
back to work and then there's the boys
in the show but that's why are you
standing behind on your Hiram's I have a
lab I picked some great team members I'm
super super excited it's time for a
female to win it's time for you to
and let's make it happen